what was the conversation
that you and i had we had a conversation
on the flight
of home from india or like yeah
it was actually going to india
and i think we sat next to each other on
the way back too i remember
bonding i remember that it's been
something that we reflected on
like many years later but i hadn't
gotten sober yet i was a [ __ ] pilot
pile you weren't dude it was like
the conversation so we're going to india
what movie was this two for number two
yeah we're going to india and they
paired stevo up with me
on the 17-hour flight to india
you guys find first class
steve you were like this was like this
was like
the beginning of the end this was like
this was the beginning of the the
gnarliest you could ever be in
doing like um drugs like you
this was going to india yeah so you got
a nose full of cocaine
before you got on the flight because
there was no i
but i can tell you this i i do know that
you did smuggle drugs because i
smoked some weed out of your ass okay
good so that came from his butt
good so yeah i don't know how it got
there i swallowed a condom i probably
swallowed like
five or six condoms full of weeds really
you didn't just do one you did like five
percent
yeah he had weed
i didn't want
for 17 hours and he's like just well
what i'm like dude um what so what's up
like what what do you come
like what's your story like like let's
we got a lot of time to talk let's talk
about real stuff let's talk about
life outside of this cool [ __ ] we do of
jackass
and we got to talk and i was like you
know man
like none of this really matters like
what matters is you're
you like you matter and you need to take
care of yourself like
everyone likes crazy stevo and we all
love that crazy stevo but if there's no
crazy stevo anymore because crazy stevia
killed himself i'm [ __ ] doing too
many drugs
and you had no responsibility for
anything i said to you i was like
you need to take care of yourself man
and i love you and i care about you
and i truly believe you have the ability
to be a
like a rad person because you were not a
rad person
at that point definitely not and and we
talked and
kept talking and and then we smoked
uh weed from your butthole later on
but you know
honestly his response was totally like
kind of
shocked i remember you were like shocked
that i would even
bring that up or talk about it like
because it was
it was like your mortal enemy uh you
didn't want to like
acknowledge what you were really doing
and i stopped you and
made you acknowledge it and you were you
were like you're really concerned you're
on my [ __ ] list for the next day yeah
was he competitive or sort of like
receptive and so
you you weren't you were competitive we
bonded it was it we had a bro down
yeah and then so that was the second but
that was three
uh how many years before you got you
cleaned up on that about two years
before
two years that two years more went by so
that was like the beginning of
yeah really taking off that stuff and
then then we did the mtv special the
24-hour takeover
before that everybody keeps talking
about this 24-hour takeoff
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude